l'heure est grave et c'est l'histoire
qui s'écrit a-t-on déjà vu un commandant
en chef ancien président des États-Unis
qui veut redevenir président être accusé
de crime aussi grave de crime fédéraux
non jamais c'est la première fois que ça
se produit vous avez entendu Jack Smith
qui a révélé la liste des accusations en
fait l'inculpation concerne des
documents classés notamment
ultra secret il y avait différents
niveaux de classification mais ultra
secret il y en avait beaucoup et ces
documents vous les voyez les photos ça a
été ça c'est dans la salle de bain ces
documents étaient conservés chez lui à
la fin de son manga et les archives ça
c'est la toilette les Archives
nationales réclamaient ces documents
pendant plusieurs mois Donald Trump les
retenez il a fallu mettre le FBI dans
l'affaire puis des soupes pénins et donc
c'est une rotation rétention illégale et
hier Donald Trump annonçait avoir été
inculpé mais se poser encore et toujours
en victime
la procureur spéciale a dit qu'il
voulait un procès rapide de speedit Ryan
les invités bonsoir votre correspondante
pour plusieurs médias français auteur de
Joe Biden le pari de l'Amérique anti
Trump et Eric Lison
Maryland merci d'être avec nous monsieur
l'ASM j'ai commencé avec vous
Sonia puisque c'est extrêmement grave
ces accusations et quand on lit les 49
pages on retrouve la transcription d'une
conversation de Monsieur Trump avec
d'autres personnes ou ils se vendent
d'avoir des documents classifiés puis il
nous dit ceci en tant que président
j'aurais pu déplacer ces documents mais
maintenant je ne peux pas alors Sonia ça
vient contredire le plaidoyer de son
innocence de Monsieur Trump n'est-ce pas
ça fait mal cette cet élément proche
totalement et je pense que le lorsqu'on
lit l'acte d'accusation
on se rend compte que c'est encore plus
grave je pense que beaucoup de ce que
beaucoup d'observateurs de journalistes
s'attendaient en effet il est Trump est
visé par 37 chefs d'accusation vous
l'avez ni notamment rétention
d'informations sur la défense nationale
dissimulation de documents conspiration
pour faire entrave à la justice rien que
pour l'entrave à la justice irrit
jusqu'à 20 ans de prison et puis on se
rend compte qu'il avait des documents
alors on le savait un classeet top
secret mais il avait notamment des
documents relevant du secret nucléaire
de la Défense nationale de la riposte
potentielle en réponse à des agressions
étrangères donc c'est vraiment des des
informations extrêmement secrètes qu'il
avait qu'il a notamment gardé ses
documents dans sa résidence de Marelle
Lago il faut savoir que depuis son après
son départ de la Maison Blanche et la
perquisition du FBI il était dernier il
y a eu plus de 150 réceptions dans cette
résidence où il y a eu énormément de
va-et-vient donc on ne sait pas qui a pu
avoir éventuellement accès à certains
documents ou entendu ces informations et
vous le montrez bien avec les photos
c'est documents étaient dans des salles
de bains des toilettes enfin c'est quand
même assez frappant de voir ça pour vous
monsieur layson l'ancien procureur
fédéral quand vous lisez ces 49 pages
avez-vous l'impression que la preuve est
accablante avec ses extraits de
conversation ces échanges aussi de
messages tech avec l'entourage et le
fait qu'on retenus les documents en
mentant ou FBI 160 crimes mais avec la
complicité d'autres personnes est-ce que
pour vous la preuve vous paraît solide
oui bien sûr
on n'a pas vu les documents actuels sauf
ceux qui est écrit dans le dans le
document développé bien sûr c'est pour
ça qu'il faudra un procès mais ceci dit
si le procès montre ce qui était écrit
là dans le Hendaye maintenant en anglais
le temps qu'ils m'ont dit qu'il passion
bien sûr c'est extrêmement grave il y a
pas de notre façon de le décrire c'était
un peu attendu au niveau de
l'échelle que les efforts et le temps
qui étaient pris par le ministère de la
Justice et les procureurs actuels parce
que ils ont pas agir avec énormément de
rapidité mais ils ont
certainement
vis-à-vis de la gravité de les documents
actuels mais c'est clair que ils ont
voulu prendre beaucoup de soins car
Trump était pas comme quelqu'un les
autres même si devant la loi tout le
monde est traité également mais avec son
statut de l'ex-président ils ont ils ont
envie beaucoup de cautions et on a
vraiment eu l'impression que si il
n'était pas extrêmement grave peut-être
il aura rien finalement mais là c'était
trop on peut pas avec leur et ça même en
croire ça
on peut seulement rigoler c'est
complètement cette absurde c'est
ridiculeuse que c'est arrivé à ce point
là et il n'y a pas de choix il faut
avancer sur le plan de pénal en fait on
se demandait pourquoi ça aurait-on
jamais pourquoi il voulait garder ces
documents les utiliser pour faire du
chantage ou quoi pour sa vanité pardon
Sonia il reste que
les citations qui apparaissent dans lac
d'accusation peuvent nous apparaître
comme des abusons on entend sa voix
reconnaître que ce sont des tas des
documents top secret qu'il n'a pas pu
déclassifier je veux savoir que
maintenant sur les républicains qui sont
tous mobilisés derrière lui-même ses
adversaires politiques hier soir quand
même avoir lu les actes d'accusation
est-ce que là il y a une brèche qui va
se produire se faire alors oui en effet
depuis hier les républicains en tout cas
l'élite du parti républicain à
Washington fait bloc derrière Donald
Trump publiquement en tout cas parce
qu'on imagine qu'en coulisse les
commentaires sont différents mais pour
l'instant Donald Trump est largement en
tête dans les sondages et donc pour les
républicains pour les élus tourner le
dos à Donald Trump c'est se tirer une
balle dans le pied politiquement en
quelque sorte mais on entend quand même
de plus en plus de voix qui s'élèvent
chez le parti républicain de de gens qui
sont lassés de toutes ces affaires et
c'est pour ça que d'ailleurs qu'il y a
quand même une dizaine de candidats à la
primaire républicain parce que certains
notamment le gouverneur de Floride Rogue
De Santis qui est pour l'instant
deuxième dans les sondages mais loin
derrière Donald Trump certains Paris sur
le fait que il y a tellement d'autres
inconnus autour de Donald Trump que
c'est un candidat peu fiable et que du
coup et bien c'est sur cela que
quelqu'un comme Rome De Santis Paris est
d'ailleurs on a appris qu'elon musk donc
le le PDG Twitter disait à des proches
de 26 je pense pas que Donald Trump
pourra remporter une élection générale
et c'est pour ça qu'il y a quand même
discrètement parce que encore une fois
si tourner le doigt Donald Trump
publiquement c'est c'est pas très bon
poétiquement de plus en plus de gens
peignent réfléchissent à la suite et un
dernier point c'est que Donald Trump lui
hier selon plusieurs sources proches de
l'ancien président révélé par CNN et
bien il se frottait plutôt les mains
avec ses conseillers en se disant que ça
allait être super politiquement parce
que plus il joue la victime plus il
arrive à rallier ses partisans mais
apparemment selon CNN ces dernières
heures l'ambiance a changé dans le clan
parce que avec ses 37 chefs d'accusation
là Trump et ses conseillers se rendent
compte que quand même les accusations
sont extrêmement graves qui risque de la
prison et d'ailleurs il y a deux de ses
en tout cas on ne sait pas exactement
pourquoi qui ont des missionné
aujourd'hui dans trustle qui était sur
les ondes de CNN hier pour défendre
l'avocat parce que les avocats mettre
les seins dans semblait avoir joué un
rôle dans dans ses falsifications dans
ses mensonges ou les faux documents
remis au FBI je sais pas si un jour ils
vont être accusés ou pas mais ce qui est
étonnant c'est de voir que Monsieur
Trump en 2016 dans plusieurs discours
c'est rapportés à la page 9 de l'acte
d'incubation disait que c'est important
au plan constitutionnel de défendre la
sécurité nationale qu'il fallait que les
documents classifiés c'est important il
fallait respecter la loi que personne
n'était au-dessus des lois et
aujourd'hui il invoque dans le fond
l'instrumentalisation de cette cause-là
pour le comme rival de Monsieur Biden
donc il dit que c'est tout ça et
politique qu'en pensez-vous
cela
oui alors au niveau que que il faut
traiter tout le monde également c'est
pour ça que c'est extrêmement important
c'est le premier raison pour laquelle il
faut avancer mais presque au même
important c'est le fait qu'il y a un
vrai menace au sécurité nationale et il
faut traiter les deux choses avec une
certaine force et c'est pour ça que
finalement même si c'est le juge qui va
décider et ça c'est un autre question
importante sur laquelle on a des
questions mais le juge va décider le
condamnation le terme de prison et
normalement dans ce cas comme ça c'est
vraiment la prison qui est indiquée et
qu'est-ce que ça montre sur la
personnalité dans l'entrepreneur c'est
quelqu'un qui a pris aucune
reconnaissance aucune appréciation et
exercer aucune volonté pour protéger les
îles de rêves du pays ce qui était sont
il était juré des défendre ça c'était
aussi évidemment
son rôle constitutionnel il a
complètement rarement se rôle que c'est
vraiment ce qu'un Deleuze et succès doit
être digéré par toutes les pays même si
au moment à la joie le sa base électoral
cette partie qui reste majorité de la
partie républicaine ne peut pas
l'accepter c'est c'est incontournable et
donc là on va voir combien de temps ce
procès ce procédure on peut dire va
prendre peut-être que le procès va
arriver après la prochaine élection on
sait pas il reste 20 secondes Sonia
quand même cette juge qui est une juge
nommée par Trump juste fédéral qui a
rendu semble-t-il des décisions un peu
absurde dernièrement
le Trump peut pas se plaindre d'être
victime de juge démocrate
oui c'est pour ça comme la dihérie qui a
beaucoup de questions sur l'avenir de
cette affaire parce qu'en effet la juge
qui devrait a priori déterminée et la
peine de prison de Donald Trump a été
nommé par Trump sans plutôt favorables à
Donald Trump et donc c'est très
difficile de savoir ce qui se passe
passer jusqu'à jusqu'à l'élection en
sachant qu'aux États-Unis on peut être
candidat et même élu même si on est
inculpé ou condamné pour un délai ou un
crime bien merci si on est à Washington
Eric Lison à Washington également
exportera fédéral merci à tous les deux
c'est on a rendez-vous mardi pour la
suite des choses merci pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI